when a movies really great we don't
always notice if a small part of the
story doesn't make much sense sometimes
though a few problematic details can
dampen all that movie magic suspension
of disbelief is one thing but huge
gaping plot holes these movies are
something else entirely
the Flyers in the vault Ocean's eleven
has so much going for it a stellar cast
an action-packed story and a triumphant
ending where the crew makes off with 150
million dollars of casino money after
pulling off an incredible switcheroo it
all goes down when Danny Ocean and his
crew tell casino boss Benedict they'll
blow up his vault of cash unless he puts
it in a waiting van may I ask how you
expect to leave do you believe I'm gonna
allow you to brave bags full of my money
on my casino do I know you're gonna
Benedict does as he's told but hedges
his bets by calling in a SWAT team and
having his flunkies follow the money and
when they finally intercept the vehicle
the bags are full of x-rated fliers and
the SWAT team back at the casino is
revealed to actually be ocean and his
team in disguise making off with the
real loot great right that is until you
stop to wonder how the fake money got in
the vault in the first place the only
people who've been in there are yen who
sneaks in via a tiny cart and ocean and
call well who rappel down an elevator
shaft none of them have bags even
director Steven Soderbergh just kind of
shrugs it off when asked about the plot
hole in the director's commentary the
bottom line no one knows man
just enjoy the heist illegal kicks the
closing scenes of The Karate Kid see mr.
Miyagi training Daniel to get him to the
semi-finals of a local tournament where
one of the bill and his Cobra Kai
competitors disables him with an illegal
kick to the meet Daniel powers through
and goes on to meet his nemesis Jonny in
the finals after Jonny does further
damage to his injured leg daniel assumes
a secret crane stance and deals a
whopping kick to Johnny's noggin winning
both the match and the love of Johnny's
ex-girlfriend except of course that the
ref has repeatedly stated that blows to
the head are illegal so who actually won
that fight probably just the audience
telling the story the social network
chronicles the birth of Facebook mostly
in flashback with Mark Zuckerberg and
Eduardo Saverin giving their depositions
about the lying cheating and backstab
that happened along the way to create
the ubiquitous social networking
platform this method of storytelling
allows the movie to jump between the
past and present offers conflicting
sides of the story and generally just
keeps the action moving along surely
from them but there's a sticking point
in one scene Zuckerberg and Sabourin are
hooking up with Facebook groupies in the
bathroom of the club they're at together
so many viewers have asked who's giving
the deposition now it's pretty likely
that this is just Zuckerberg memory
instead of the deposition so why is he
remembering the other guys hookup creep
City no matter it's still entertaining
hence the four Golden Globes in three
Academy Awards missing The Hangover is
one of the funniest raunchiest wildest
comedies ever the plot centers around
Phil Stu and Alan's attempts to track
down their missing friend Doug after a
night of debauchery in Vegas after two
days the guys finally find Doug it turns
out that he's actually on the roof of
the Mirage Hotel in which they're all
staying sunburned but otherwise no worse
for wear after the relief wears off
we're left to wonder how did he go
unnoticed for that long don't casinos
have crazy security and cameras
everywhere including rooftops besides
wouldn't doug have tried to somehow get
noticed during those long 48 hours seems
like he could have at least yelled or
something future-tech the main gist of
interstellar story is that the world is
being plagued by a mysterious blight
that destroys crops and depletes oxygen
levels the resulting food shortages and
breathing problems mean all of humanity
is on the brink of extinction
so NASA pulls together a team to head
off on an intergalactic journey to find
new inhabitable planets but not meant to
save the world we're meant to leave it
along the way coop the pilot who accepts
the assignment to lead the mission gets
hurled around the galaxy at one point
ending up in a black hole where he can
communicate with his daughter Murph
through a tesseract behind her bookcase
and doesn't get back home until she's an
old woman makes sense well sort of time
and space do crazy things but you know
what else is problematic the fact that
even before coop heads off to the
gargantuan galaxy it's revealed that the
technology to artificially grow crops on
other planets already exists so why not
just grow them on earth it's such a big
plot hole that the movies novelization
actually addresses it the blight got
into the biodomes to wolves
[Music]